[Music]
are you guys aware of the obsession in
many cultures including japan with the
poop emoji
[Music]
oh like where there's merch and stuff
there's merch there's all kinds of
behind it accessory and eyes are real
like the swirly [ __ ] soft serve with
eyes yeah it is cute yeah it's cute it's
a cute little turd
well there's a new there's a new twist
on it um
your legs and hands but there's a bunch
of accessories out there about this
right like the poop emojis like there's
pillows all kinds of [ __ ] is that not
the first nft versus like a monkey
well no cats are the first time
is there a competition to poop the exact
shape that it is in
uh that would be really a really good
article but no
that's a really good idea uh so one of
the things that that people are have
have released is a a poop emoji bath
bomb
oh
oh no
what do you guys think it's made out of
it cinnamon i hope it smells like cacao
something like cinnamon
and does this smell good guys
butter and cocoa oh yeah yeah that's
good
does it smell like herbal essence
it smells like chocolate oh it's
chocolate
it's poop that they made smell like
chocolate chocolate
how do they do it
huh and [ __ ] in this bowl real quick
i want to see i want to see a portrait
of the guy who showed
anthony's face more than i believe
steve's what do you believe
i don't think it's human feces
here's the thing it's human feces but it
smells like chocolate
they they incredible it's incredible
it's actually crazy
new technology nah that's me it's made
out of [ __ ] chocolate
[Laughter]
chocolate doesn't make me horny like
that though no poop does
[Laughter]
no i mean like like i don't want some
chick taking [ __ ] bath bomb [ __ ] you
associate bath bombs with sex
no
you're right
hey yeah
are you guys into like a drizzle me with
syrup and let's eat it oh that's a mess
that's a legitimate i tried a couple
times but it's not fun it's not fun
right i will one day desire to try a
line of cocaine off of a titty but like
i just seen it in the movies dude my
buddy that's not messy my buddy has a
story about how he was hooking up with
this one girl and she brought like
whipped cream and he was like oh okay
and she started putting whipped cream on
you know the down below region the penis
and she started to performing fellatio
on him and he was like this is not okay
and he just
he was awesome he goes dude it was
sticky it was like gross it was the
worst thing ever just gotta suck it all
up and he was just like i'm out dude and
he just
i've never heard a guy say no to a
[ __ ] branson lee is he homosexual
a little bit okay yeah yeah he's like
i'm not used to you know no stubble
i need to feel some beer shadow come on
dude
i like it when the beard is tickling my
bones
well you have no hair on your hands
what's up with nothing to do with the
cream yeah
unless you have some [ __ ] chompers
yeah
i had never heard a guy say notable she
had braces but it was it was the it was
the whipped cream part that he just was
ruining that's like ocd with cleanliness
no he's he's gonna be quite normal
actually i was actually surprised he's
this guy he [ __ ] a lot too he's a
[ __ ] this guy be [ __ ] you guys ever
had a girl blowing you and then you're
like
this is pretty disrespectful won't you
stand up
no
why don't you stand up and below me and
national anthem was playing why'd you
stand up and play you stand up on the
bed she stands up
and that's a respectful [ __ ] why
don't you say the pledge of allegiance
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't take a knee at this time
what are you calling
yeah get up colin
have you guys take have you guys are you
guys into like bathing with your chicks
when it's time to like [ __ ] no it gives
me nightmares well
i do i look i do love the feeling of
being freshly cleaned yeah i do too yeah
i like to be scrubbed me too and then i
feel like that incentivizes things like
you know oral because you're like
everybody knows you it's like you're
clean you're clean i'm clean we're good
same page i want to go like this in the
shower and just
rotate around and then she scrubs me
like that
that'd be pretty cool like a car wash
yeah yeah instead of the car wash
rotating around me i'm the i'm the one
wrote she has a giant brush and she just
yeah [ __ ] wanted to take joe's such
an emperor dude
yeah dude you really you do have emperor
vibes
dude what's your blow job fantasy i want
to stand there and then get scrubbed
like a car wash yep
okay nobody's ever said that before
i think i'm gonna i have an idea so when
i get a house i'm gonna create a shower
where i get those lazy susans on the
bottom of the shower oh okay and then i
can have a button which slowly rotates
me yeah cause then you could never quite
get a good
like that when you're doing
your isolation why don't you just get
one of those new school things where the
shower heads on top
and then it gets everything ones where
they come out the size don't they you
ever seen those yeah it's illegal to
have more than one shower head in the
shower now in california because the
water wastage yeah oh wait good luck
dude are you serious good looking
forcing that [ __ ] too much water
it's illegal really well if they find
out yeah because you can't even in all
shower heads there's a restrictor built
in that limits how much water comes out
yeah and if you get that installed by a
plumber yeah sometimes the problem will
go hey you want me to take the
restrictor out
for 200. it's like a black box for cable
tv but you know like some showers
they'll have like some coming out of the
sides the top whatever yeah you would
want against code to install that what
like because it's it uses too much water
it's like [ __ ] come on the drought
yeah and and one dude's getting that's
like having an ar-15
they're exceptional
they're like you don't no one needs that
many shower heads okay nobody's that
dirty joe needs it dude joe needs to be
scrubbed i want to go to one of those
things where you know like um in those
hazmat suits and then you've got to get
all the chemicals out
and he goes
from all sides i'm like why can't we
have that yeah why
so it seems expensive because there's no
chemical warfare going on around you
right now yeah that's why you know in
those science labs they have that
fountain yeah dude with the eye blasters
i always wanted to try it but i didn't
want to get the chemicals in my eyes to
go there but i wanted to just go there
like it's a good idea
and then boom black let's see what it
felt like
but by that time i was already like
early 20s and i knew how to behave
myself damn what a shame man yeah you
missed the window
i i did always use uh i did always enjoy
using a hydrogen peroxide when you cut
it oh it would like sting but to see the
bubbles come and stuff like that i was
always like this is this is tight have
you ever put in your eye
why would you do it i [ __ ] up one time
so i've got contacts
and um i mixed the bottles no wonder
you're almost blind i mixed the bottle i
didn't know and i went like this
and then i just started [ __ ]
screaming like crazy and it was like the
driest i've ever felt in my whole life
it felt like someone [ __ ] came like
this i know actually i know what that
feels like because there's the contact
solution with the hydrogen process that
one that would that yeah and then you
have to let it sit for like six hours
yeah and it starts fizzing yeah but then
i was fizzing on my eye and i felt like
the [ __ ] it felt like the oven came and
just baked i know that
so what do you do with that do you rinse
it
you take it out if you can but it burns
so much but even then you just have to
wait for the pain to pass can there be
lasting damage or is it just like being
maced
well i don't know if anything is
probably amazing but man that was not
fun sometimes i think we swap back and
forth who's the dumbest [ __ ] in this
room
we're constantly passing the tour yeah
we're like we're like all it's like hey
can i have the show real quick can i
have the show cool the dumbest pup in
the room
let's rank the room real quick break the
room on today's day because like i put a
[ __ ] pie in my dishwasher but you're
a child well sure but like it's pretty
[ __ ] stupid yeah you're experimenting
that's just hypotheses yeah yeah yeah
that's all it is that's smart
scientific you're pretty you're pretty
dumb today yeah thank you that's what
i'm trying to say
yeah actually you did have a pretty good
contribution now dumb you could have
been that's true normally you have some
rational [ __ ] it's usually just joe yeah
usually it's yeah usually or it's me
telling a story about someone that died
but that's not dumb or it's like nick as
an adult
yeah yeah because right now i'm like i
am definitely i'm the youngest in the
room so i'm gonna do the dumbest [ __ ]
out of all of us i don't think so you're
like the most buttoned up and like adult
person here i think i don't think so
true you had like a stable relationship
since high school nah i think what it is
though clean haircut i'm just boring i
think i'm just kind of naturally boring
in a lot of ways are you fishing for
compliments no i swear to god oh [ __ ]
god i was not christian
no you're stable though i just know what
i
special of that response
he was talking about railing that girl
with two [ __ ] yeah
and then
yeah he said one [ __ ] nick was like
oh we ever seen one [ __ ]
he's like oh well i mean it's pretty
good wait do you see two i like that
we're glazing over the fact we should
mention spoke for him on that stripper
thing oh yeah dude he was the [ __ ] yeah
and anthony was like let's go [ __ ]
strippers
ashley wanted to do cocaine one time and
then nick's like not gotta work out
tomorrow
it's like no i have to work out i can't
i can't be difficult but guess what me
and anthony did a bunch of coke that
night when you guys went to bed
this is nick's narrative right now
[Laughter]
the leader of the kid just bro no no
dude ryan's the lead request
[Music]